foreign
let's talk for a second about
sleep
food intake
weight gain all that kind of good stuff
and part of the reason I want to ask
about this is because it seems this is
based on a comment that you had sent to
me a few days ago
about
and maybe you can tell me how to
pronounce this Endo cannabinoids am I
saying that correctly cannabinoids how
do you say this what's the proper
pronunciation on that endocannabinoids
there we go on endocannabinoids because
I'm wondering if this somehow ties into
the earlier conversation we were having
about THC
Maybe not maybe it does but certainly
people who have smoked a lot of weed
which is not me but will be from The Ore
for that matter we've had enough Edibles
will be familiar with the munchies
very consistent very consistent for a
lot of folks who
who might dance with the wacky tobacci
on occasion
so could you introduce this in any way
that makes sense to you just in terms of
of how sleep relates to food intake
relates to weight gain sleep and food
timing all of that jazz because
the endocannabinoids or changes in
endocannabinoids caused by Sleep loss
seem to increase hunger food intake on
thus weight gain it makes me wonder like
why would that be the case
why is that I have observed as someone
who's had a lot of sleep trouble that I
become ravenous or at least much more
compelled to overeat when I don't sleep
it's striking and I've certainly noticed
that too when I sort of travel if I'm
you know going back home to the UK to
England and my sleep is usually always
rough with that I definitely noticed the
change in my appetite and the evidence
is really very strong now that when
sleep gets short unfortunately it will
lead to a waistline that can expand
and the the early evidence came on to at
obesity Diplomat it's a very nice way to
put it exactly and my Twitter handle is
changing five minutes here and then at
some point there will just simply be
hashtag cancel called just leave
Diplomat which is kind of yeah but
anyway so the the early evidence looked
it it takes a village Internet it's
making streams come true all right sorry
go ahead the world will be a better
place without me I'm sure so uh two
appetite regulating hormones one was
called leptin one was called ghrelin and
leptin by the way is a hormone that says
to your brain okay don't eat it we think
of it almost like the satiety signal
that makes you when you've had food it
makes you feel Satisfied by your food
and so you don't want to eat more and
then ghrelin on the other hand it does
the opposite it is the I want to eat
more hormone it increases your appetite
graylin G stands for go eat the cookies
yeah exactly sort of G for my stomach is
growling and I definitely want to eat
more
and what they found was that when you
limit people to let's say just four to
five hours of sleep a night for several
nights
you see a dastardly change in those two
appetite hormones firstly what they
found was that leptin the don't eat the
I'm sort of satisfied with my meals tidy
signal that dropped by about 18 percent
if that wasn't bad enough levels of
ghrelin which is the hunger hormone that
increased by 28 so in some ways it's
almost like physiological Double
Jeopardy that you're getting punished
twice for the same crime of not sleeping
once by a loss of the signal that says
don't eat you're full with your food you
lose that signal and then if that wasn't
bad enough you ramp up your ghrelin
signal which is I'm hungry hunger levels
would increase by around about 24 to 25
percent depending on the study
so that was sort of the emerging
evidence on the appetite regulating
hormones and by the way that doesn't
necessarily lead to a consistent change
in eating more of every type of food the
unfortunate thing is that the class of
food that you start to increase your
greatest desires it's not just that you
want to eat more it's the things that
you want to eat more of are the things
that are more obesogenic so these are
more carbohydrate-rich Foods simple
sugary Foods ice cream sort of sweets
Etc and also they found an increase in
your preference for eating salty snacks
which can put you towards a path of
Greater hypertension so
so that was the evidence of the basic
appetite regulating hormone level but
then the more recent data came out
you're right that all of us even if
we're not smoking the
the wacky tobacco as you described all
of us have our own cannabinoids that we
release inside of our brain and our
bodies we have naturally occurring
cannabinoids in our brain and they're
called the endocannabinoids meaning that
they come from inside of us endo
and you're absolutely right that when
you give people exogenous cannabinoids
like THC it makes them hungry you get
the munchies but what they found was
that when you sleep deprived individuals
this has got nothing to do with THC or
cannabis or smoking weed you increased
the amount of these cannabinoids within
the the brain and within individuals and
so all of a sudden
you start to see perhaps it's not just
these lectin and ghrelin that are
changing to conspire to increase your
hunger in your waistline but it's also
that these endocannabinoids are
increasing and you can then start to ask
well you know why what why would that be
the case how can we explain those things
currently we we don't quite know one
hypothesis is that
the only time when you see
other species deprive themselves of
sleep because human beings in truth are
probably the only species that will
deliberately provide themselves of sleep
for no apparent good reason but animals
will do it occasionally and the most
common occurrence is when they're under
conditions of starvation
and so here under those conditions the
brain releases awake promoting chemical
called erection and the reason is
because the brain has figured out I'm
under conditions of starvation it must
mean that my ability to forage for food
in my standard perimeter during the time
that I'm awake is not yielding enough
food so I need to push myself to be
awake longer to forage in a wider
perimeter and therefore to find and
solve this
sort of caloric deficit so one
possibility is that because you are
deprived of sleep you're sort of getting
this this signal of let me ramp up my
Hunger even more let me drive up my
motivation to go and search for food
because otherwise I'm going to be in a
mission-critical kind of break glass in
case of emergency situation but we don't
truly understand why these these
hormonal patterns go awry we certainly
know that you will increase your intake
of food
we then want on to discover that it's
not just about what changes in your
endocannabinoids or in your hormones
because in fact choices that you make
for your foods are controlled by your
brain that's the central dominating
decision pivot point for here so we took
a group of individuals and we deprive
them of sleep and then we gave them a
full night of sleep and it was a
counterbalance study where they both go
through both full sleep and without
sleep and the next day we place them
inside an MRI scanner
and we started to show them different
images of food that range from really
unhealthy Foods
sort of like pizza and donuts and ice
cream all the way up to really healthy
different types of foods and they had to
rate the desire that they had for those
individual foods and we also did
something a little bit dastardly to make
it more ecologically valid we told them
and we did do this that one of those
items that they said that they found
desirable we would then serve them when
they came out of the MRI scanner and
they had to politely please eat that
food so it should just forced them to
make sure that they're making the
choices correctly not what we found is
that the brain you started to rate these
obesogenic Foods as much more desirable
and the reason was that the control
regions of the brain once again in the
prefrontal cortex was shut down whereas
more hedonic Drive centers within the
brain dopaminergic centers and also the
amygdala which is also controlling
hedonic food desires those ramped up in
terms of their activity and that's a
profile that we typically see in
patients who are suffering from obesity
it's this profile of what we would call
a brain state of hedonic eating that you
shift over into just going after
desirous Foods unhealthy Foods so it was
a two-part equation changes downstairs
in the body and then changes upstairs
within the brain
there have been since some cities
looking at dieting without sleep which I
think is probably some really
fascinating data but let me just pause
there for a second